very much the president is still pushing
Seattle's mayor to reclaim a
neighborhood the protesters have turned
into a quote cop free zone police
abandoned a local precinct there on
Monday after the area became a hotbed
for demonstrations over the death of
George Floyd and a Warner has more on
the city's response to the protests
Mayor Jenny Durkin fired back at
president Trump's warning that he would
send in troops to Seattle the threat to
invade Seattle to divide and incite
violence in our city is not only
unwelcome it would be illegal still the
president continued his complaints if we
have to go in we're gonna go in these
people are not gonna occupy a major
portion of a great city after multiple
nights of violent clashes police in a
show of de-escalating tensions in the
Capitol Hill district boarded up their
station and left now the area called the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone or chazz is
being controlled by mostly peaceful
protesters activists have camped out
vowing to stay unless their demands
which include defunding the police and
racial equality are met in a video
message Seattle Police Chief Carmen best
said she did not order officers and
personnel to abandon the city's East
precinct after several days of unrest
ultimately the city had other plans for
the building and relented to severe
public pressure we're going to evaluate
[Music]
but there is no plan to do that at this
moment the autonomous zone has turned
into an almost street fair like
atmosphere with free food art displays
and outdoor movie nights but there have
been some reports of armed people
patrolling the streets in lieu of police
demonstrators have renamed the building
the seattle people's Department this
also is our building as we paid for this
and we pay for their works and
everything that they do is supposed to
benefit the people and many say they
have no plans to leave we're not
stopping these guys from going to work
but we will occupy the space for the
best of our ability utilizing our rights
for CBS this morning and a Warner San
Francisco